il est fan on n'est pas dans le bon
paquet on fait alors maman à temps
observe soit fait en fait il faudrait
avoir le truc brûler la verdure et après
les montagnes collines on préfère un
pacs du croissant et on s'en va vivre et
la plus lourde à vibrations des eaux
l'argent sale
ok c'est pas toi les briquets bon c'est
pas top du tour
dans ce port
aller un peu plus vite les comptes en 60
ans l'expert s'est quittés dans la
douleur certes un peu trop tard
le tout toujours ok on fait avancer en
dépend très verticale
alors là on à l'arbre qu'il nous faut
pas faire le plan que diane roulé à mon
avis on se sent il est pas mal celui là
non on continue c'est un tout petit peu
dans ok ok je couperai ok ok cela est
possible qu'ils développent plus vite on
en 60 ans
sellal inverse qu peur maintenant alors
là on passe au dessus ce placard pas
possible et que tu bois tu peux
désormais assez vite parce que commence
à être un japon bon vin car étant
les caf à la fin du zoom c'est possible
6 4 de france le dollar va continuer à
tourner parce que j'étais ok qu'est ce
qu'on fait vite là pendant 60 ans soit
aimé sa vie prend des heures à votre cap
cependant pas dans cinq ans on va vibrer
pour l'instant bay arrière planer dans
ce cadre ne fait rien alors en plus
sévères comme plus rapide dans la valley
la regardent peut-être que juste juste
au passage la gloire d'un sac et un peu
polémique ou tu veux pas sur cette
montagne la relaxe dans laxe raison le
contrat s'élève à les pousser
c'est naturel et quelque part c'est
beaucoup plus flagrant pression sur le
plateau à côté de tous les trains entre
temps au prince et de l'accord là où le
mec qui découpent dans leur village et
comment l'as tu le vois à coire ok coûte